was it my imagination
[Music]
talk to me i have visions
i write them down and people pay to read
them
scott had a history of becoming unstuck
to reality where'd she grow
he called it being gone
[Music]
come back
[Music]
i'm on a bull hunt what's a bull hunt
like a scavenger hunt scott and his
brother made up when they were kids
mrs landon i just thought i'd give it
one more try in person
scott's unpublished words need to be
collected
examined you're never going to see his
papers
she won't let them go i'll get those
papers for you
[Music]
scotland's books changing
do you remember that night you asked if
i was crazy
i believed in it that's how strong his
imagination is
there's a place i'll take you there
what is this
[Applause]
you solve all the riddles find all the
clues
and you get a prize where we went today
was it real
[Music]
or was it my imagination
i said doctor
mr empty
would you tell me what's wrong with me
he's gone he was pushing me till it was
[Music]
was it real or was it my imagination
you